a massive coveted revolt in canada could
be heading to america next tens of
thousands of truckers are currently
protesting the country's strict vaccine
mandates and their organizers say
they're looking to take on the u.s
government next
somebody's got to fight this great reset
and i think teamwork with our northern
neighbors and us we got it we expect it
to grow exponentially over the next uh
several days next couple weeks we're
looking at launching california to d.c
beginning march 1st it's coming together
it's coming together very quickly
a lot of public support on the american
side
the huge show of force apparently
striking a nerve with canadian prime
minister justin trudeau
i have attended protests and rallies in
the past uh when i agreed with the goals
when i supported the people uh
expressing their concerns and their
issues black lives matter is an
excellent example of that
but i have also chosen to not go
anywhere near protests that have
expressed hateful rhetoric
all right jesse he's decided that he's
not going to go anywhere near protests
that talk about hateful rhetoric and he
says that uh they are uh being violent
toward their fellow citizens isn't he
ginning up more hate isn't that how you
divide just the way it's happening in
this country he looks like he wet his
pants i have not seen
any barbarians with tiki torches and
pitchforks these seem like reasonable
people that just want to work
and you know when when canada gets angry
that's when you got to think wait a
second maybe we've hit a breaking point
here these people
they are our number one trading partner
yeah bigger than mexico bigger than
china if we have a problem with that
supply chain where there's
ships idling off the coast imagine we
can't get goods and services back and
forth the northern border
we're not going to be able to buy
anything and all you need to do is a
politician judge and i figured it out
it's really simple you just have to
listen to people how hard is that you
listen you say you didn't even fake
listen yeah let's go uh-huh uh-huh and
then you just do basically what they
want just kind of at least in the same
range
right you know what greg you're right
about that all right but you know what
greg didn't he go too far when he called
those truckers uh men in tin foil hats
oh no no he
canada should be ashamed of this
oh god i almost said douchebag
he's a calo leader this is a guy who
backed the fraudulent blm from his safe
little perch and then he sells out well
he did that to help alleviate his own
blackface scandal that's why he did it
then he sells out his own citizens he's
not a pm he's a bm
but anyway uh these are not normal
activists that's why you have to stand
for again battle movement
these are not normal activists these are
not college kids they're social justice
warriors these are hard-working on the
spectrum of social activism they're the
least likely agents of change which is
why you should take them seriously and i
know that the media and and and uh the
left want to insinuate violence and
insurrectiony kind of rhetoric and
they're hoping for it and they might get
it there might be a freak who does
something wrong but that's what they
really want because it's weird how
everything's switched it's like you know
the
workers of the world unite
and there are no leftists there to
applaud it good point yeah well but but
you know what i'll i'll tell you that
their requirements that you have to have
a vaccine in order to cross the border
and then you have to quarantine so and
then and then miss work i mean this
really is crazy stuff feral you got to
agree you can't expect a trucker to
quarantine and by the way this guy ends
up um because when he got the the
omicron he went into hiding he's a wuss
well he went into quarantine
uh no he went into hiding they called
him a cat i think that
you know the truckers have their right
to protest and uh it is so annoying when
they stop traffic and they inflict
misery on innocent third parties have
nothing to do with their beef but my big
problem if uh prime minister trudeau is
correct uh there have been uh
confederate flags oh my god uh swat
stickers uh
with in these truckers uh convoys uh if
that if the prime minister is correct
and i'm only exciting him how does he
know that
then that indicates that there are
amongst them at least some very rare
give me some complaint of a fight of an
argument a police report don't give me
this nonsense somebody had a flag and i
didn't like it and therefore they're
racist stop with that i love the idea
that people in canada have the
confederate flag for the love of yeah
also truckers are quarantined yes that's
the nature of their job they are in
their trucks also you want to know why
you have an inflation problem
how much is bacon now yeah how much do
you think it's going to be after this
20. how much do you think it's going to
be for your steak canadian and your ribs
right
biden and my poutine are on the wrong
side of this that's right i like poutine
you know what
that's
with the fries yeah the gravy um okay
biden and trudeau should get on the
phone right now and say guess what
because of omicron the way the thing is
gone we've got x amount of people
vaccinated we'll keep trying to do it
we'll team up with the truckers make
sure we have a vaccine program going but
this ends tomorrow
hope spring's eternal but it ain't
happening hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else